the Barbie doll was introduced to the
world by Mattel back in 1959 throughout
the years we've learned some pretty
surprising trivia facts about her but
there's still so much more to uncover
about the most iconic doll to hit store
shelves if this is your first time
visiting our channel don't forget to
subscribe and please give this video a
big thumbs up because today we're
sharing 10 surprising things you didn't
know about the Barbie doll it costs a
fortune to recreate her look a woman
named blondie Bennett has dedicated her
entire life to transforming herself into
a real-life Barbie doll blonde his
obsession with the toy compelled her to
spend over $30,000 in plastic surgery
procedures including five breast
augmentations chin liposuction and him
the therapy sessions to make her feel
more ditzy and confused she says she
wants to be seen as a plastic sex doll
so she wants her personality to be as
painless as possible
she had a rebound relationship on
Valentine's Day in 2004 Barbie and Ken's
perfect relationship came to an abrupt
end during their time apart Barbie had a
rebound relationship with Blaine and
Australian boogie boarder the
relationship with Blaine didn't work out
either and Barbie soon realized that Ken
was the only guide for her the couple
got back together in 2011 Barbie changed
her status back to in a relationship on
Facebook and she and Ken have been
happily together ever since
her very first car Barbie has had more
than a few fast hot and flashy cars in
her automobile collection her very first
bride was a 1962 austin-healey 3000 mk2
roadster the car which was created by
Aaron a corporal Mattel was available in
bubblegum pink and an orange brown shade
the two-seater was perfect for Barbie
and Ken to cruise around town in style
she was originally a teen fashion model
the original Barbie created in 1959 was
marketed as a seventeen-year-old teen
fashion model she wore a black-and-white
zebra striped swimsuit and she wore her
hair in a cutesy ponytail it wasn't
until later when the doll was redesigned
having more adult appearance she
received a complete makeover from her
facial expressions to her outfits there
are more Barbies than baby's born in the
US
during the first year of production more
than 350,000 Barbie dolls were sold
these days the doll is still one of the
most popular products in the toy
industry every second three Barbies are
sold around the world
that's 24 times more than the average
number of babies born in the United
States each year ken has never put a
ring on it
after meeting on the set of a television
commercial back in 1961 Barbie and Penny
became inseparable although they've had
a break up in some bumps along the way
the relationship has remained quite
solid throughout the years but despite
their history together in decades-long
romance the two have never been married
we think it's about time Ken puts a ring
on it how about you she keeps her makeup
simple although barbie has been known to
experiment with her look throughout the
years she likes to keep it simple when
it comes to her makeup her lipstick is
usually pink which is no surprise
considering it's her favorite color and
when it comes to her eyes the color
brown is most frequently used for her
eyeshadow she was banned in Saudi Arabia
you would think the iconic doll would be
embraced all over the globe but that's
simply not the case
Barbie was actually banned in Saudi
Arabia by the country's religious police
in 2003 the announcement was made that
the country declared the doll was an
immediate threat to morality due to for
revealing clothing not everyone sees her
as a role model the doll has come under
fire for her unrealistic body
proportions if Barbie were an actual
person she would be five nine she would
weigh a hundred and twenty pounds and
have a body measurement of 38 18:34 in
comparison the average woman has a body
measurement of 41 34:43 many women's
advocacy groups believe that Barbies
unrealistic shape causes young girls to
suffer from body image issues and they
might be right in a 2006 study the
American Psychological Association found
that girls who played with Barbie dolls
had a much lower self-esteem she has
never been pregnant Barbie comes from a
pretty big family and she has seven
siblings in total but when it comes to
starting a family of her own
the doll has never been pregnant she
isn't missing out on motherhood though
her best friend midge has two kids and
we're sure Barbie loves to spoil them as
if they were her own
which of these Barbie facts shocked you
the most react in the comments section
below and don't forget to give this
video a big thumbs up